for some of you flying just got a lot
longer see on top of causing death and
destruction in ukraine the war also has
huge repercussions for the economy and
global industries like aviation the
russian invasion of ukraine has led to
some western airlines having to add
hundreds of miles to their flights as
they take long detours to avoid closed
russian airspace it's been a dramatic
ban for many airlines now it isn't
affecting all routes but if you're
trying to get to here in northeast asia
from here in europe or even here in
america then the quickest route for some
airlines was to go straight over russian
airspace and now they're having to go
around so what does that mean for you
well for now it means you're facing
longer flight times fewer flights and
higher ticket prices and with no signs
of that airspace reopening anytime soon
some in the industry are bracing for
even more disruption it's not a
long term solution for the carriers let
me explain firstly let's start with how
long you're in the air for
take thin air flight ay73 between
helsinki and tokyo normal flight time
around nine hours
that flight would usually go straight
over russia the shorter distances
reduced fuel burn
and faster journey times for customers
made it an attractive option for
everyone but now that airspace is closed
to western countries that russia called
unfriendly so now that flight is taking
a new route over the arctic circle
adding a whopping four hours to that
journey time but that's nothing compared
to what cathay pacific are considering
for their route between new york and
hong kong
instead of flying up through russia and
over the arctic circle the company said
it was exploring flying around the
atlantic ocean which would make the
flight the longest in the world covering
around 10 350 miles and taking 16 to 17
hours cafe said that favourable winds
could make that journey possible as they
would help push the plane along but
those winds are already tapering off if
this issue is still around in the winter
the flights will become longer and on
some occasions
airlines may have to make a technical
stop
those longer flights are also affecting
when you can fly because of the extended
flying times traditional schedules and
traditional departure times are not
necessarily suitable they're either
having to leave earlier or they're
having to change the scheduled time of
departure from asia back to europe
finnair told me that longer flights and
scheduling conflicts meant that instead
of operating 40 weekly flights to five
destinations in japan they were now only
operating seven weekly flights to tokyo
and there was already less flight
availability due to the coronavirus
pandemic as many airlines are operating
a reduced frequency to asian countries
that are still under strict kovid 19
rules a classic example would be perhaps
where
lufthansa would in normal times be
flying twice daily from frankfurt to an
asian destination they would perhaps
only be flying once a day at the moment
right now lufthansa says avoiding
russian airspace is only economically
sustainable because few people are
traveling to and from asia but analysts
and airlines tell me that if demand for
travel to and from asia recovers before
russian airspace reopens then that will
create even more scheduling problems and
make those seats even harder to come by
so for passengers fewer seats and longer
fuel burning flights all mean one thing
higher ticket prices according to
analysts those ticket prices were
already high to begin with due to pen
top demand for travel from europe but
with jet fuel prices more than double
what they were a year ago many airlines
are passing additional fuel burn costs
onto passengers there are airlines that
are now charging fuel surcharges adding
more to the airfare the airline industry
has been decimated in the last two years
what it cannot do
is absorb the additional cost of fuel
cathay pacific wouldn't tell me if they
were passing those fuel costs on to
passengers but lufthansa told me that it
was too early to evaluate if the changed
routes would affect operational costs
and fares and finae told me higher fuel
costs from avoiding the russian airspace
are reflected in the pricing for all
airlines so what will it take for these
routes to return to how they were before
the pandemic well while much of the
aviation sector is strongly recovering
from the coronavirus pandemic it will
likely take lower fuel prices more
planes flying to asia and the reopening
of russian airspace to see these routes
return back to normal so if you're
traveling across continents anytime soon
particularly between europe and asia you
might want to pack an extra book as it
could be a pretty long flight
hey you may think 17 hours is a long
flight but in 1958 a cessna called
hacienda spent 64 days in the air
without touching down so now you know
and if you want to know more don't
forget to subscribe